this is how prices are decided at Asia's
largest onion wholesale Market farmers
and Traders from nearby areas meet in
the town of La salgao every morning
today their mood is somber they say they
are struggling because of falling prices
I lost more than thirteen hundred
dollars this season I'm now in depth I
can't even run my house I'm worried if
I'll be able to grow onions next year
I'm scared my dip will increase and I'll
be stuck in cycle of loans
India's largest producer of red onions
recently prices dropped by half creating
a big crisis in the region Growers are
blaming this on Surplus produce
estimated to be around 30 percent
Farmers here say government policies are
making it difficult for them to export
onions climate change has also impacted
on in Supply higher than usual
temperatures and unseasonal Rain have
reduced the shelf life of these onions
forcing Farmers to bring them earlier to
markets before they rot
Traders say they're trying to revive the
market before the summer Harvest arrives
the encouraging customers to buy at
lower prices and working with Farmers to
find long-term Solutions
these red onions cannot be stored for
too long but pink onions have a longer
shelf life so we are asking Farmers to
expand warehouses for those we are also
suggesting they grow varieties that can
be exported to Regions like Europe and
the Middle East so next time there's a
crisis here we can sell the produce
there
last week thousands of farmers started
marching to Mumbai to demand financial
assistance they ended their protests
after the state government agreed to
their demands those include subsidizing
prices and waiving loans some say the
solution is only a temporary fix
the entire system needs to be overhauled
right now political parties interfere
and decide who's allowed in the market
there should only be buyers and Farmers
no one else additionally Farmers need to
learn to balance onion production with
demand so they can get a good price
harvest season is expected to begin next
month Farmers hope they'll benefit from
new policies and start recovering their
losses
Western India